daughter Caitlyn was probably 15. Jacob
was like 11 and a half 12. and my
daughter just starts to cry hey guys I'm
so embarrassed that I haven't shared
this with you but I'm dating Amanda
which is her best friend I go okay and
then Jacob goes I'm in an Armenian gang
I was like what
I turned to my wife I'm like before I go
any further do you have anything you'd
like to admit
so I said to my daughter I go babe she
goes no I'd like to hear about the gang
first they go yeah me too hey man tell
me what that means we stood at lunch
together
and we make fun of the other Armenians
not other Armenians you're not Armenians
then I said to my daughter we don't care
who you date if that person is good to
you you're good to them you respect each
other that person makes you feel good
about yourself and loved we don't care
who that person is but no more
sleepovers you know what I'm saying
and Jacob was like why no more
sleepovers I'm like just be Armenian
dummy you don't need another